hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and Deadpool 2
released a full trailer that actually
shows us a ton of footage from the movie
not but I needed a whole actual movie
here guys I could just watch them do Bob
Ross in Toy Story bits and peeper fect
Lee happy but now that we know that test
screenings for the movie are scoring off
the charts
let's break apart all the footage ins
trailer shot for shot like the obsessed
psychos that we are we're hidden details
that could explain why this movie is
gonna be so so great and swear we're
warning in case any of these predictions
into being right cool cool yeah cool
it's cool let's get started okay in this
first clip our favorite taxi driver and
getaway driver dopinder waits for
deadpool rocking out to all out of love
by air supply first this kind of
reminded me of the use of juice newtons
angel the morning and the opening
credits of the first Deadpool but
actually this song is a little nod to
Ryan Reynolds past career remember he
sang the song and Van Wilder hit by a
big truck are you okay hey you know
right gets hit by big trucks in all my
movies also this whole bit of the hero
running from a mob and screaming at the
getaway driver to start the engine seems
like a reference to the opening sequence
of Raiders of the Lost Ark let's move on
[Music]
guys okay in this section we get a sense
of what Deadpool has been up to since
the events are the first movie and some
of those adventures might include a trip
to Japan
looks like Deadpool is taking up the
Yakuza here I love the move where he
decapitate Stu dude but the head stays
in place so he gets to punt it off by
the way the director of this movies
david leitch known for his stunts
direction in the movie John wick the
whole stylized violence and vibrant
color gradient of that movie has
definitely worked their way into the
action for this movie as well and it's
very exciting
and then we see Deadpool impressively
sticking the landing after a front flip
in these strippers stilettos for
whatever reason guessing for
weaponization purposes those heels are
sharp as hell but I think my favorite
detail about this is look at the Marquee
in the background showing the drink
specials one of them reads burning
Basterds MC a burning bastards MC is
apparently the name of an erotic book
series by writer Dayne classified as
alpha biker romance which is a thing
that I now know exists thanks Deadpool
moving on
sorry I'm late I was rounding up all the
gluten in the world and launching in a
space where it can't not hurt us ever
again kiss me like you missed me read
here Deadpool returns home late to
Vanessa and his excuse ear about
rounding up the world's gluten and
launching it in the space where it can't
not hurt us again it's actually
reference to Superman for a quest for
peace and that movie which you know
happened Superman gathers up all the
nuclear weapons in the world and throws
them into the Sun only we could do this
for gluten the world would be just as
dangerous let me know what in the hell
is this
my name is cable
I'm here for the kid what the kid mover
guy
okay in this section we get a sense of
the general plot of this movie as we
suspected cable is after this young
mutant Julian Denison's character now
reminder that cable is a time-traveling
techno-organic mutant you got it yeah
just go check out my other breakdowns
for more explanation of his ridiculously
complicated background which is actually
kind of a point of his appeal honestly
he is obsessed with time paradoxes and
saving or destroying elements from the
past to alter of future timelines in
previous examples I pointed out but that
stuffed bear that you see on his side
could be a reference to cables Hope
storyline in the comics where he
protects this young girl hope she's
really the key to the future of mutant
kind and this mission sounds like in
some ways the opposite of that Hope
storyline like he wants to hurt this kid
because of some horrible threat that
this kid might become in the future
Ashley if you saw Ryan Johnson's movie
looper that's kind of the same premise
with Bruce Willis going back in time to
kill a kid to prevent a terrible
super-powered villain from raining hell
on the future now there has been much
speculation over what mutant Dennison
will be he appears to have fire
abilities so something for Saint pyro or
sunspot but one interesting theory that
I came across is that this could be a
version of Evan from the recent all new
x-men comics also known as Genesis or
kid apocalypse he's a young mutant to
bears a striking resemblance to
apocalypse and it turns out he's
actually a clone of the world ended
mutants perhaps that's why cables so
obsessed with the kid let me know what
you think but let's move on kids give us
a chance to be better than he used to be
he needs you
you're a lot smarter than I look I let
cable kill this kid okay the title card
here contains a joke from the studio
that brought you 27 dresses and The
Devil Wears Prada which is a callback to
the first step pulls romantic comedy
promotional campaign and kind of a
teaser for that movies dig at Fox
Studios from the studio that
inexplicably showed is my mouth shut the
first time Vanessa and wait here
discussed the idea of having kids
becoming more mature and more
responsible than their wild romantic
past right as we get these little visual
callbacks to that sexy calendar girl
montage in the first movie there's this
picture of them wearing Santa hats which
is a different one from Polaroid selfie
that Vanessa took of them in the
Christmas sweaters of that scene suggest
in that another Christmas at least has
gone by and the scene is suggesting that
Wade will take on more of a father
figure role the denizens character
protecting him from harm from cable and
honestly from himself
let's move on it's hard to hear you with
that pity dick in your mouth we're gonna
form a super duper meet him topic
morally flexible and young enough to
carry their own franchise for 10 to 12
years okay some interesting stuff here
Deadpool Todd's negasonic teenage
warhead with up on the nose watching
from behind with the pink hair is a new
character being played by CEO Lee
kutsuna based on the way she handles
that electrical whip it looks like she
could be the mutant surge from the new
mutants
Serge absorbs electricity at all times
she's to wear these specially designed
gauntlets to help regulate the
absorption here's also this shot of Wade
spinning in professor X's wheelchair
this prop is actually a big deal to use
they featured it in the TV series Legion
on FX and the actors on this show
described how exciting it was to see the
people from Fox wield this thing on a
set now there were reports recently the
Deadpool 2 scheduled six days of
reshoots and that they include featuring
a new secret cameo for the movie now the
leading theories that this will be
Professor Charles Xavier not sure if it
would be a McAvoy or Stewart other ideas
suggested it could be Hugh Jackman as
Wolverine or since Disney owns Fox
properties now a crossover for an MCU
character being like Nick Fury er Tony
Stark so it would be kind of crazy for
one of these guys to show up just a few
weeks after Infinity Ward comes out
unless it's Hawkeye
someone who is uh apparently not to
anywhere visible in infinity war be fun
to see him riff on how he got left out
mostly interested in these shots of
paintings of foreign presidents eat
Lincoln in Barack Obama and what do you
guys think those containers are in front
of the portraits my first thought is
that they were like urns containing
cremated ashes but uh Obama is still
alive and well relatively young and
healthy and Lincoln wasn't cremated so
you guys only know what you think these
are in the comments and I just love this
joke about Wayde putting together a
super-duper team young enough to carry
the franchise for 10 to 12 years
basically he's talking like a movie
studio exec creating the New Avengers
type franchise and we see one of the
members of this team Terry Crews his
character we're gonna beat down one of
those DMC soldiers now in the last
trailer breakdown I speculated DMC could
stand for department of mutant control
and the thought then was that crews
would be playing x-force character GW
bridge but the next section of this
trailer reveals who he really is
so let's move on x-force you're
absolutely right now let's go get our
okay here if you pause this first part
at the right second you can see Deadpool
flipping through black and white
headshots and the one on top shows Terry
Crews in the name bedlam bedlam it's
another mutant who made his debut in
x-force he's able to generate an
electromagnetic field and sense similar
powers used by other mutants but
honestly the head shot underneath is
even more interesting that is comedian
actor Rob Delaney the hell is this guy
doing in the movie now the name on the
picture says Peter it could refer to
Peter Rasputin the original name of
Colossus and we never saw Colossus and
his normal nonmetallic form the first
Deadpool so maybe they're casting the
lanius is human self it's also possible
that the Peter might also refer to Pete
wisdom he's from the x-men offshoot
comic series Excalibur wisdom runs a
British spy agency am i 13 he dresses
nicely like this Peter does and he
throws hot knives of energy for his
finger tips and it's not totally clear
but that does look like Rob Delaney with
the moustache in the Far background of
that aircraft and the last trailer this
character wore a helmet that looked like
the one worn by shattered star he's a
gladiator figure from the mojo verse in
the comics meanwhile the dude sitting in
front of them is definitely bill
skarsgård the actor who played penny
wise in the remake of it last year just
crazy how many great performers are
keeping under the wraps for this movie
in a last trailer skarsgård had his face
covered up making people think he could
have been someone like chamber he's a
mutant to fire psionic blasts from his
chest others have speculated that he
could be playing axel clooney aka
zeitgeist from the x-force comics he
spews gelatinous energized from his
mouth I mean that's why he was covering
his face and last trailer it's a super
gross part that would be really fun to
see skarsgård play also notice the pose
that Deadpool makes here crossing his
arms into an X as he names the x-force
Domino asks if that's a little
derivative referring to the x-men vs.
the x-force it's yeah it's super
derivative but I also like how the
gesture is a little derivative to
essentially the what condom salute and
black panther and before I move on there
are more shots of what I think is
Deadpool crossing katanas with the
Yakuza again this time in a Japanese spa
and if you look closely in the
background one of these guys is
clutching his ass making me think that
Deadpool might have just you know stuck
one of those katanas right up this guy's
pooper yeah yeah okay let's move on move
on
tell me they got that in slow motion you
and the right thing is messy in this
section there are some shots of Deadpool
covered and powder and ash I notice how
that gives them kind of this gray and
black color tone this could be a nod to
the grey colors of the suits worn by the
x-force including Deadpool in the comics
let's see my favorite shot in this
trailer Deadpool performing some
chiropractic treatment on himself guys
the way his body gets mutilated it's
just so fun and cartoony wonderful let's
move on that is why Sisterhood of the
Traveling Pants is pure pornography
finished college in this section
Deadpool fires some kind of sonic blast
from a weapon at cable this might be
some kind of a mutant suppressing gun
used by the DMC maybe the only way to
restrain cables techno-organic powers in
this moment we also see Deadpool wearing
this yellow and blue x jersey crossing
the police line my guess is he's mocking
negasonic here coming to her as a member
of her team X to help them save the day
really he needs her help for something
else then we get this awesome shot of
Deadpool taking a shot in the hand
twisting around and shooting the driver
back in the face actually this looks
like the first part of the shot that we
saw in the previous trailer when
Deadpool's steering the truck wall
looking upside down through his legs I
feel like they just choreographed all
the action in this movie by using one of
those bendy wooden just ala men from
Ikea like what am Not sure always can we
twist Deadpool's body to make like fun
violent stuff and then Deadpool has this
great line about The Sisterhood of the
Traveling Pants being pure pornography
now this is kind of a meta jab at Ryan
Reynolds real-life wife Blake Lively
she's a star of the sister of the
Traveling Pants movies the two of a
history of publicly trolling each other
posting pictures of the other that are
like unflattering or once it cropped
them out thank you for bringing us in on
your adorable cruelty lion live notes
yeah I'm gonna go with that let's move
on to the last section
it lives up to the hype plus plus they
probably won't even make it three yeah
why would they stop it - you killed it
okay so the trailer closes with this
exchange between Wade and weasel where
they rip about the sequel and its
chances to make it to a third movie he
says if you stop it - you killed it this
honestly could refer to a lot of movies
how x2 was a great sequel but then Fox
ruined the franchise with x-men the last
stand
or how Blade 2 was great but then the
one Ryan Reynolds is in plate 3 sucked
or maybe Reynolds is just making fun of
his wife again who made a really bad
sequel the sister - Traveling Pants Ryan
Reynolds generally has a very
self-deprecating sense of humor when it
comes to sequels tweeting this trailer
by saying the movie falls somewhere
between the Godfather Part 2 the best
sequel of all time and dirty dancing
Havana nights ooh which is a sequel of
all time but I'm gonna turn it over to
you guys who do you want the new secret
cameo and Deadpool - to be one of the
Charles Xavier 's Logan Channing Tatum
is gambit one of the Avengers or hey
what about Danny knows I would love to
see Josh Brolin like Professor Klump
himself comment down below to let me
know your thoughts or tweet me directly
Eddie a vos to follow new rock stars on
Twitter for updates on our videos like
this video and subscribe to do rockstars
for all of our in-depth breakdowns of
Deadpool trailers and Marvel and DC
stuff Star Wars you know I'm sure we're
just kind of nut all over this movie
when it comes out on May 18 or fanboys
it's a whole live skies it's sad I know
just go click on some of that related
content you jerk I mean thanks for
watching love you behind